- All the mental health
stuff are you open about?
- I'm open about everything.
I'm very rock 'n roll.
- Are there no go zones?
- No, no go zones.
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
- You have this incredible gift.
When you open your mouth
everyone listens (laughing).
I don't know if it's because there's a lot
of swearing (laughing).
But you have that gift,
and you can turn the world
around in a certain way.
How you gonna use that? I
know you do it for business,
but how else?
- You know I think I have a lot
of ambitions with how else.
You know over the last
five years especially,
really the last three,
as my awareness and
internet fame has grown,
it's been very clear to me
that I touch on subjects,
whether it's parenting,
whether it's happiness,
you know my great passion is to redefine
what success looks like,
and turn it from something
that is around money
and make it around, you know,
happiness and just feeling light.
And so, you know, even though that's
a very daunting question
I think about it the same way
that I've built all my businesses,
which is one day at a time,
one step at a time,
one piece of,
one piece of content at a time,
one interview at a time,
one talk at a time,
execution.
- Yeah, amazing.
- And patience.
I think, I think one of the things
that I feel very confident about
is I think there's a
lot of us in the world,
people that are watching you, I,
people behind the cameras
that have great ambition
to leave a good impact,
to do good, to spread happiness.
But I find a lot of people are impatient.
To make a huge impact on happiness
in the world, that's boiling the ocean.
That shouldn't happen overnight.
That shouldn't happen in three seasons.
That should be in perpetuity.
And so patience.
- So what do you think underneath,
like I've been watching a lot
of your content,
and you're such a great person
to speak to about business,
but I wanna know more about
Gary V behind the business.
And it feels like,
have you taken a turn more towards
helping individuals moreso
than even the business
side of things?
- At some level.
You know, three, four years ago
I was very passionate
about putting out these
really tactile business advises
that I thought really could help people
seize the opportunity
that the internet is.
And I kept trying to figure out why
they weren't doing things.
Why weren't they executing?
Why weren't they putting out content?
And it led me to a path
of like wait a minute,
there's a level of confidence
and a level of not being insecure,
and a level of dealing
with judgment that I have,
which has led me to far
more strategic conversations
around mindset.
And so yes, I think as I
kept digging down the well,
you know the reality is is that
so much of my business advice
is predicated on
foundational mental strength.
So you're not gonna put yourself out there
if you're worried about a comment
in the comment section,
or what your mom is gonna think.
And so yeah, I think over the last
three or four years the evolution
of listening to why people
weren't doing things
that were very clear and working
has led me down a more mental path.
- Absolutely.
So when you say,
I mean a, sorry.
A big key you say is not
caring what people think.
How do you train someone
to stop caring so much?
- To me I think a lot of
this is exercise, right?
By saying stop worrying
about people's opinions.
Are you gonna live your life based
on somebody else's opinion?
Don't worry and think back
to the way you were parented.
Your insecurity comes from some
of the missteps of your parents,
but don't over judge them,
it is, what it is.
It's on you, accountability to get there.
I think it's practice.
It's just practice.
- Yeah.
- It's just practice.
- Building a muscle.
- It's building a muscle.
Wake up every day, get a bad comment,
and this is why I'm so prolific
in my daily content.
I just wanna keep talking about it,
and hoping that,
to your point,
and thank you for saying it,
I was born with a gift that
makes people pay attention.
So if I've got them in
I'm just gonna pound them.
There's not a whole
lot of different things
I'm gonna say over next 70 years.
There isn't much else to be said.
There's very clear
foundational aspects of this.
So I think it's practice.
And I think the 813th time
that I say it is the day some woman
in Hunter Valley says you know what
today's the day I'm gonna jump,
and she makes a video.
And she's scared to do it.
And there's some tough comments.
And it's a little bit easier
because she's practiced
building up the courage.
It's no different than the kid
who wants to learn how to swim,
or kissing a girl,
or riding a bike.
You're building yourself up, right?
You're like today's the day,
today's the day. You know when
you put your toe in the water
and you said today was gonna be the day
and you didn't do it,
and you went home.
And the next day you go to the
pool. It's a, it's practice.
- Just building that muscle.
So taking you back to your childhood,
I know that school was a bit
of a struggle,
and I know there's so many out there
that could relate.
What do you say to them?
- I mean modern schools across the globe
are not built for the realities of 2020.
So it doesn't mean you
can be disrespectful,
it doesn't mean that
you just need to quit.
Please recognize, if
you're not a great scholar,
that a lot of hard work
is in front of you.
But yes I think that if
you're a parent right now
and watching this,
most parents struggle with their children
not doing well in school today
because they worry about the
judgment of other parents.
- That is so true.
- Which is really unfortunate.
I look into the camera
and I please to parents of today,
please don't parent your children based on
other parent's opinions.
- Yeah.
- You know it's a,
it's very sad to think that parents
are willing to force their kids
to do things that they deeply know
their kids are not about
because they're worried about
what the neighbor's gonna say.
For the kids that are watching I say look,
you need to be self aware.
I know school can be a drag,
please recognize if you don't do it
that you're gonna have to
work hard and for forever,
you know 'cause you're gonna
be starting at a lower point.
That diploma's not gonna
get you in the door
so you're gonna start at the dirt.
I think there's a lot of
entitlement from bad students.
They're like ah I'm a bad student
but I'm gonna be an entrepreneur.
Being an entrepreneur
is ridiculously hard,
and so I highly recommend a lot
of self awareness both at the parent
and the kid level gets deployed.
- How do you know that you can
make it as an entrepreneur?
- You don't.
- You just gotta try.
- And be patient and hustle.
- Yep.
- Is that the key?
- That is the key.
Now look I'm sure there's a lot of kids
or grownups who actually
feel the way I did,
which was I knew,
but I didn't really know.
You know it felt natural,
it felt like I had it.
It seemed that every time
I put my foot in the water
a lemonade stand, selling
some baseball cards,
trying to shovel snow,
that I did well.
But until you do something
you don't fully know.
I think the key right now is to make sure
you're not doing it 'cause it's cool,
'cause everyone else is doing it.
Everybody wants to start a business.
Everybody's got a side hustle.
Everybody's got an app idea.
That is a modern day phenomenon.
That is a reaction to the internet itself.
It's appropriate.
But before you tell me you're gonna build
the next Facebook or Uber,
before you're gonna make a million bucks,
why not make $100.
Why not actually put your
foot in front of you.
And so you don't necessarily know,
but if you love it,
if you love it,
if it just gets you going,
the idea of buying and selling something,
or starting something,
or building a community,
you must scratch that itch.
Because regret is probably the thing
that I fear the most.
And I see, to me the
saddest thing in the world
is an 80 or 90 year old that I come across
that is deeply grounded in regret.
'Cause it feels like, you know,
it feels like you can't do anything
about it anymore.
And a lot of people have it.
- You wuuldn't have any
regrets so far, would you?
- No, 'cause it's too early.
I'm sure I will too, we're all human.
But it's too early.
You know the great thing about being 43,
especially the way that
I contextualize time,
I don't even feel like I've
lived half my life yet,
and so it's tough for me to regret.
But actually that's not fair.
I would actually tell you,
you know it's funny it
doesn't come across as regret,
but there's definitely a golly gee shucks,
I wish I had a little
more fun in my teenage or,
in my teenage years or 20's.
You know when I talk about
how hard I worked in my 20s,
only the five or six people
that were closest to me
really actually know how true it is,
how extreme it is.
I really, really, really
didn't take any vacation time
or weekends in my 20's,
and I do have a level of regret of that.
A couple of weekends with the boys,
a couple of trips could
have done me some good.
- So driven.
Now I know you come from amazing parents,
an amazing background and
you talk a lot about children
and not having those same opportunities.
What was it about your parents
that you could pass on to other parents?
- My parents have two extremes.
My Mom was deeply optimistic
and built self confidence
in me and over loved me.
And my dad was deeply pessimistic,
very much around work ethic,
and saw the world differently.
And in those extreme contradictions
I think I became the enigma
or anomaly that I am.
Now there's also some DNA in that,
meaning a lot of people (sound cuts out)
both my parents.
You know my parents even joke like
you've really made us out
to be these super parents
and it's because I'm
focused on seeing the good,
so that's how I see it.
- That's, you're hardwired
to be optimistic anyway.
- I do believe that, I do believe that.
But I do think it was encouraged.
I do think that if my
dad and mom switched,
and I grew up with a parent
that was deeply pessimistic
from one to 14 that some
of that optimism would have
gone from an eight to a seven
versus where I think with
my mom an eight to a 10.
So I do think, you know,
this has been figured out
long before I came along.
This nature/nurture
environment is very real.
And so yes I think there are things deeply
DNA wise about me,
but I do think the way I was nurtured,
the environment I grew up in
and the parenting I had
had an impact as well.
Much like I look at my sister
who's only three and a half
years younger than me, right?
For me, by the way I know
all the noises going on,
I see everybody behind camera.
I love this.
So if you're watching at home,
I love the chaos so.
- We're backstage, this is what happens.
- Um, my sister's only three
and a half years younger than me
and she's wired to be pessimistic.
And I think she's a three who got parented
and had an older brother
that moved her to a six.
Again, if she was raised
by my grandmother,
who was very pessimistic
she might have been a three
that became a one.
- Yeah, interesting.
- And so that's how I see it.
- Yeah.
Where do you see yourself zero to 10
on the happiness scale?
- 11.
- Every day?
- Every day.
- Really?
- I'm driven by gratitude.
I'm incapable of being upset
around things that don't matter.
Everything besides the health
of nine people doesn't matter.
When a parent of mine passes away
that 11 will become a zero.
- Yeah, right.
- For a day, a month,
a year, I don't know.
I haven't crossed that bridge.
But I have put myself in a
very interesting box mentally,
which is my perspective is binary.
It is black and white.
Either the nine or 10 or 11 people
I love the most are healthy
and woke up this morning,
and didn't die and thus
I'm fully happy, or not.
And losing an account
or having people write
something bad about me
or having a PR headache,
or something didn't work
out the way I wanted
or somebody stabbed me in the back,
or, it just, it resonates for a second,
maybe it gets,
I mean extremely difficult things
that I notice contemporaries struggle with
carry three minutes of
anxiousness with me,
65 seconds of inconvenience.
Me, if it's traumatic
maybe a couple of hours
before it translates into
this really doesn't matter.
- So it's a little,
what you say to yourself
at the time,
or do you practice (mumbles) over time?
- I probably have spent the last 15 years
of my life making
pretend that my mom died.
- (laughing)
Are you serious?
- Yeah.
(laughing)
Yeah.
I do a lot of things where
something great happens
or something bad happens,
and I make pretend and then the phone rang
and my mom died.
So how would I feel?
Would I feel like this huge trophy
I just got meant anything?
No.
Would I feel like this terrible
thing that happened in
business today was terrible?
No.
So, yeah, I've been practicing
for a very long time.
- That's a really
massive way to look at things.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I love that.
- Yeah, it really works for me.
- I can see how it would work,
but it's not something
anyone would think of.
- Yeah it's something
I've been thinking about
putting out more in the world.
Like really just think about it.
Like just really wake up
and go to sleep every night,
and make pretend the singular
person you love the most
just died in a horrific accident.
I know it, I get it, I get it.
But look, I wanna be very empathetic.
People watching this,
we all know the majority
of the world deals with issues.
Watching a man who just said he's 11 on
the one to 10 happiness scale,
that can come across very insincere.
And the followup to why I'm there
is an extreme different
kind of thought process
that isn't talked about
in contemporary times
that I would like to
argue is worth a debate.
Whether it works for others or not,
I don't know.
But it is what I do.
It is what I do.
And-
- And-
- Please.
- People are seeing you
as seeing so successful
they wanna know how your brain tics.
So maybe these little things,
the things we haven't thought about
that we should be thinking about.
- And if they look at
my success as an ability
to walk around very light
versus the money I've made
or the followers I have,
then the hack that I just
gave is even more powerful.
And I would argue that a lot
of my business success comes from the fact
that I have not had to take a lot
of hours ever in 25 professional years
to sit and worry about something
that's happening outside the business.
I'm giving it my all, care free,
and that's how I see it.
- (mumbles) to when you were at school.
So what was the tricky things
that made you get the D's
and the F's?
Was it, were you dyslexic?
ADHD?
- Probably, probably.
I don't know.
I wasn't diagnosed with either,
but it was a different time in the '80s.
It was deep self awareness
that everything that was
going on in that classroom
was completely irrelevant to what
I was going to be.
- Yeah.
- It was either a mix
of unbelievable audacity
or incredible self awareness
at such a young age,
and probably a little bit of both.
And I just remember being in fourth grade.
I remember vividly sitting
in Mr. Momar's science class
saying I'm gonna win anyway.
I don't care about Saturn.
- (laughing)
I love that.
- I don't care how-
- Did you say it to the teacher?
- No. I was, you know,
something I think a lot
about actually is how bad of a student
I was and how disruptive in class I was
'cause I was always a little bit
of a showman in hindsight,
very much a class clown.
But unbelievably liked by my teachers
for somebody who was disruptive
because I think what I,
the reason I wouldn't say that was
it's very uncomfortable
for me to be disrespectful.
- Interesting.
- So I would play, you know, right?
I would understand where I
could get away with things
that would seem like lighthearted or.
- It sounds like you can completely
read people's mindset.
- 100%.
- Yeah.
And that must be a
massive skill and mindset-
- It is the skill.
- Business, yeah.
- It is the skill of life.
- Yes.
- If I could wish anybody
anything besides health,
it would be emotional intelligence.
- Yes, absolutely.
Where do you see yourself
20, 30 years' time?
- You know, I don't think
in those kinds of ways.
My intuition is a far
more complete, stronger,
thoughtful version of who I am today.
With probably a lot more awareness.
I intuitively have this deep feeling
that everybody on earth
is gonna know who I am.
- I absolutely agree.
- I really do.
I really do.
So, you know, probably in
a very interesting place.
- How, like you've got
the stage ready to go.
What, if you could say
something to the world
and raise their happiness,
what do you think the key thing is?
- I think giving more than you take
is an incredible way to get.
I think that uh,
I think that karma is practical.
I think that doing the right thing
and being the bigger person
in every situation is always right.
I think that happiness
is remarkably quiet,
and negativity is extremely loud.
And so do not allow that to confuse you
of how great things are.
I think those things stand out to me.
- That's brilliant.
- Of loud and quiet.
You know, I think a lot
of people right now,
you know social media exposes us.
It doesn't change us.
And what it,
in my true belief that negativity
is always louder than positivity.
Louder, not truer.
What you're seeing right now is a lot
of people arguing and complaining
and spitting poison on social.
Yet, the 99% that are silent are actually
in a good place.
And back to your point
if I had the world stage,
the reason I would wanna push that
is I would like to create a call of arms
of if you're in a good place to share.
Like I'm proud that this morning
when I was brushing my teeth in Sydney
I literally looked at my phone,
it is my framework to think that way,
and I tweeted a blue heart.
A blue heart emoji.
Why blue, I don't know.
Not necessarily my favorite color.
I just saw, like.
- Just sending some love out to the world.
- Actually I do know.
Subconsciously I think somebody
might have an attachment
to a blue heart.
And when they just see it that might,
if 16 people are effected
by that in a positive way.
And so I think we need a lot more of that.
Why do we only tweet when we complain
about an airline?
How about when you had a lovely flight?
Why can't be tweet that we
had an incredible stewardess?
- That's so good.
- Why don't we do that?
- Let's do it.
- And I think we need to
make positivity louder.
- Absolutely.
- As a collective.
- That's what we're on about.
Tell me, do you have any kind
of spirituality or faith
behind what you do?
- Not really.
You know it's interesting,
my family grew up in the Soviet Union.
And what a lot of people
don't know about communism
is that religion is outlawed.
- Really?
- All religion is outlawed by communism.
So starting at my great grandfather level
the majority of my family
never really practiced
the faith of being Jewish.
So we are not deeply religious.
I don't really even,
you know there is no spiritual guide
or scriptures or books I've read.
I'm just deeply intuitive
around my humanity and kindness,
and that's what I follow.
- So you don't necessarily believe in God?
- You know it's funny,
I have always and still feel that
if you ask me that
question I would say I do.
But I don't really think
of it much more past that.
And I don't know if I'm checking the box
because it's a thing to say.
I will say that I'm
unbelievably cynical to religion
in the fact that I think a lot
of it underlining
creates lines in the sand
to hate others.
- Absolutely.
- So I think the manifestation
of modern man and woman of religion
is something that should be questioned.
You know it's my great fear right now
with the rise of nationalism
around the world.
Anything that says we're Americans
and screw everybody else,
we're Australians and
screw everybody else.
We're women and screw everybody else.
You know Jews or Muslims or Christians
and screw everybody,
anything that does anything that says
I don't like another fellow human
is deeply uncomfortable to me,
and that comes in the form
of many different tribes,
whether religion or country or gender.
Yeah so I struggle with that.
- How would you feel
about being president?
- I would feel that if
I was born in America,
which is a requirement to be president
of the United States,
that I would run for president
of the United States.
(laughing)
Probably now for that matter.
I think I would win.
- I think you would win too.
- I think I would win.
- There's something very unique
and special about what you're doing.
- I think what gives me a shot
is that socially and humanity wise
I have a lot of liberal characteristics.
However, business wise and merit wises
I have a lot of conservative.
And I'm able to carry those two.
And I think in America right now
unfortunately we're pushing
in opposite directions.
I think you can be a
winner and a sweetheart.
And that's what I'm pushing for.
- You've got the balance going on.
- Thank you.
- So just gonna throw some
quick questions at you.
- Please.
- Don't overthink,
not that you would.
- Cannot do.
- Just spit it all out.
- It can be long winded but
not overthinking. (laughing)
- So if you had three
people over for a barbecue
who would you love to have there?
- Dead or alive?
- Both, either.
- Randy the Macho Man Savage
and my two grandfathers
that I never got to know.
- Awesome.
- What's your kryptonite?
- That's a really good question.
Um, interesting,
what is my kryptonite?
- He's lost for words.
- Yeah, which is rare,
but it's a great question.
Uh, the health of my family.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Definitely.
The health of my family.
- What do you want your children
to say about you as a dad?
- That he showed us how to live,
he didn't tell us.
- Do your children have a swear jar?
- No,
but they're very aware
their father swears a lot.
- They should start one,
and they'd be multi-millionaires.
- They would be awfully well off.
- You've done very well today, refrain.
- I always know when I'm on TV.
(laughing)
- And lastly, where's your happy place?
- Within my own head.
- I wanna be in your head
just for a day.
- Within my,
you know it's funny
you just asked that question
and the first thing I saw
was head against an airplane,
in the shower washing my hair,
I'm desperate to figure out
how to over communicate
whatever infrastructure
I have around my mindset
because I'm sure for everybody listening
that quick answer is
an awfully good answer
for the human race.
- How many people can say that?
- Not as many as I'd like.
And that is.
And there's a level of guilt
that I (sound cuts out)
drives this enormous need
to communicate at scale
around this issue.
- That's why we love what you're doing.
- Thank you.
- 'Cause everyone's just soaking it up.
- My very last question.
- Please.
- I know you're a sports fan.
- Yes.
- Have you got an AFL,
AFL team yet?
- I do not have a footie team.
- Now you do.
- Uh-oh.
- Okay.
(laughing)
The (mumbles).
They're on top of the ladder.
- Very pretty.
- And this is a very cool cap.
- It is a cool cap.
- And, um, that is now your official team.
- This is fantastic.
Thank you.
- Can we just do a little with that on.
- All right guys, I'm sure a lot
of people are gonna be super upset,
and start hitting me up
on social, but I'm in.
- (mumbles).
- So good.
- Okay thank you.
- Thank you.
Cheers.
Thank you everybody.
This is a nice hat.
- It's a cool hat isn't it?
- Great hat.
- We're from Geelong,
but Geelong (mumbles).
(crew chatter)